HAL VARIAN: Hi, I'm Hal Varian.
I'm the chief economist
here at Google.
It's a great
pleasure to introduce
Erik Brynjolfsson
and Andrew McAfee.
I've known Erik for so
long, I can spell his name.
[LAUGHTER]
It's really quite
an achievement.
I haven't known Andy that long.
One F or two Fs?
ANDREW MCAFEE: See?
We'll get there.
HAL VARIAN: Well,
we'll get there.
Someday I'll learn it,
but I read their book,
and now I understand
all this effort
that I put into spelling-- it's
not worth anything anymore.
Two Ss, one F, all this stuff--
I just type a couple letters,
and then some automatic
machine completes the spelling.
So this is just the first
and simplest instance
of what we're all going
to encounter, according
to the authors, so they're
going to spend the next 45 or 50
minutes telling us about what
other jobs computers are going
to take.
Thank you.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
Thank you, Hal.
It's a pleasure, and
according to our calculations,
you will be the last person
to be replaced by a robot.
Oh, you did make one
mistake in that intro, which
is, we're not going to
speak for 40 or 50 minutes.
The reason we're
here is, we want
to hear a bit from you about all
the amazing things that you're
doing, and the
questions that you have,
so Andy and I going
to try and speak
for maybe for 15 or 20
minutes, and then do Q&A,
and we'll answer
whatever questions you
have about the research
we've been doing at MIT,
and the other companies
we've visited,
and the people we've
interacted with, and will
hopefully will be a very
lively dialogue that way.
We realize that the best way
to learn about these issues
is not to retreat to
our offices at MIT,
and close the doors and windows,
but to get out and interact,
and hopefully it'll be something
that'll be beneficial to you,
as well.
Now, the reason
we wrote this book
was, in part, out
of our own confusion
about a number of trends
that were going on,
and they came from
different groups
that we've been talking to.
We visited a lot of companies,
like Google and technology
companies in the Valley.
We also spent a lot of time with
technologists at the Media Lab
and CSAIL, the computer
science and the iLab
at MIT and elsewhere, and
heard about the wondrous things
that technology could do.
We had a better experience
riding in the driverless car
than Hal did.
And we came away
from that with a lot
of the infectious
enthusiasm and optimism
that a lot of technologists
have about being
able to solve all sorts of
problems with technology.
But we also spent a lot
of time with other groups,
in particular economists.
I was just at the American
Economic Association meetings
in Philadelphia, and it reminded
me why the economists are often
called the dismal science,
because they weren't nearly as
optimistic as our
technology friends.
They pointed out some stats
there weren't so encouraging.
Median income has basically
stagnated since the 1990s.
The employment population
ratio has fallen dramatically,
and hasn't improved, although,
as you may have heard,
unemployment has
gotten somewhat better.
That's mainly because more
people have dropped out
of the labor force, not so
much because people are hiring.
And there's a whole
set of other statistics
that aren't as
encouraging, and so you
contrast not just the
rapid innovation, but also
some of the encouraging
economic stats,
like the fact that we have hit,
last month, the record wealth
in the United States-- $77
trillion record GDP, record
productivity, but yet these
numbers on median income
and employment, and
it struck Andy and I
as kind of a paradox, arguably
the great paradox of our era.
Tracing the numbers
back a bit, we
found that these numbers
weren't always so decoupled--
that through most
of the 20th century,
and from what we can tell,
the 19th century as well,
although the data
aren't quite as good,
these numbers all rose in
rose in tandem together.
Productivity, employment,
median income--
they were relatively
tightly coupled, but then
starting about 15 years
ago, they became decoupled,
with productivity and wealth
and aggregate continuing
to grow significantly,
but the other numbers
tailing off, or stagnating,
or even falling some.
And this accounted for
these different perspectives
that the technologist
or the techno-optimist
had when they look at
one part of the story,
versus some of the
economists, who
were looking at another
part of the story.
And we wanted to
try and reconcile
how that could be true.
I mean, was one
group right or wrong?
And, in fact, they
were both right,
but they were looking at
different parts of it,
and furthermore, most
interestingly, we
think that both
aspects of this-- both
the record productivity
and wealth,
and the stagnating
median income--
actually have a
common cause, and that
is the fact that technology
has been racing ahead,
but many people have not
been keeping up with that.
There's kind of a dirty
secret in economics
that not many people
recognize, because it
hasn't been so important
before, and that
is that while technology
can grow the economic pie,
and really is what some
economists jokingly say
is the only free lunch
that we believe in,
there is no economic law
that says that everyone's
going to benefit from
those technological gains.
It's entirely possible that some
people will be made worse off.
You've heard of the buggy
whip manufacturers that
were put out of business
when Henry Ford introduced
the automobile.
Well, sure, there
are some people
who may be made worse off.
It turns out that the
size of that group
can be almost arbitrarily large.
It could be 50%
or more of people
who don't share
in those benefits,
and the data suggests
that in the past 10,
15 years, that's been the
pattern that's been emerging
is that technology has
been making the pie bigger,
but most of those
benefits have been
accruing to a
relatively small group.
Maybe 60 to 70% of them have
been accruing to about 1%
of the people in the
past decade or so,
and a lot of that, while
there are many forces at work,
a lot of it has to do with
the nature of technology.
To give you an example,
consider a simple application
like tax preparation.
So TurboTax can do your taxes.
Many of you probably
use TurboTax.
I do.
It's a simple piece of software
that has codified that process,
and reduced it to a basic
set of steps-- digitized it--
and once it's become
digitized, guess what?
You can make a copy of it.
You could make 10 copies of it.
You could make 100
million copies of it,
and the marginal cost of
that is very, very low.
Anything that's digital can be
reproduced at nearly zero cost.
What's more, each
copy is virtually
identical to the
original, and it
could be transmitted
almost instantaneously
anywhere on the planet.
As Hal writes in his book,
"Information Rules," which
you should all read if
you haven't already,
these characteristics of
free, perfect, and instant
are not common for most
other goods and services,
to say the least, and they
lead to sometimes some
unusual economics.
Some of those economics
are what we call,
winner take all markets,
because if someone has made
a tax-preparation program, you
don't necessarily want to go
out and buy the hundredth-best
or the thousandth-best
or the 10,000th-best program.
You want to buy probably
the best one you can find.
Maybe there's some
room for a small amount
of differentiation, if people
have slightly different kinds
of needs, and so a very
small group-- maybe one--
will win the dominant
share of the market.
Sticking with tax
preparation, that
means that the people at Intuit
have done very, very well.
There are some
billionaires there now.
All of us, as consumers, have
done well, because for $39
we can get tax
preparation, and we
have a lot of consumer surplus
and benefits-- ease of use--
that we wouldn't
have had otherwise.
But there are a bunch of
people in the tax-preparation
business, at H&R
Block and elsewhere,
that may have had a
college education,
may have had some
skills that they've
invested a long time in,
and now they're not really
adding a lot of value anymore.
What they do isn't
really all that useful
to most of the rest of
us, and as a result,
the ranks of people who say
their job is tax preparation
has fallen dramatically over
the past five or six years.
And it's, of course,
not because taxes
have gotten so much easier.
It's because technology
can now do that job.
Now, that's just one example,
but it's, in many ways,
a microcosm of what's happening
in many other industries, where
you can codify more
and more processes,
and reduce them into a digital
form, and then replicate them.
Marc Andreessen
has famously said
that software is
eating the world,
and he's got a point
that this digitization is
at the core of more
and more industries--
not just the traditional
software industries,
but, of course, music and
media, manufacturing, finance,
retailing.
In fact, it's hard to
think of an industry that's
not affected, with the possible
exception of our industry,
education, which I
think is next in line
for that kind of
revolution, and that
means that the same
kind of not just
technology, but the
same kind of economics
is coming to more
and more industries.
A number of economists,
including our colleague, David
Autor, and others
at MIT have a look
at what's happened to what they
call the skill content of jobs.
You take the overall
occupations in the economy,
and look at the underlying
skills required to do them,
what you find is
that those jobs that
involve routine
information-processing tasks,
like, for instance, tax
preparation, but also travel
agents, bookkeepers,
secretaries-- those jobs have
been the ones that have shrunk
the most over the past decade,
because automation has
affected those tasks the most.
Now, in doing the
research for this book,
Andy and I spent time visiting
companies like Google,
and we came to the
conclusion that it
wasn't just that
machines were getting
good at routine
information-processing tasks,
but they're getting good at
a broader and broader set
of tasks.
I think Andy may be
talking about some
of those in a little while,
but there's a whole wider
set of applications, and really,
in some ways, amazing things
that machines can do
now, many of which
I think people in this
room are probably inventing
and discovering, and
that means that as
disruptive as the past 10
years were-- and it was
a very disruptive decade-- we
think that the next decade is
going to be even more
disruptive, as it's going
to create even more wealth, even
more productivity, even more
possibilities, but
also, it's going
to change the skill
content of more jobs.
It's going to mean
that more people will
find that the existing
tasks they're doing
aren't adding value to the
economy in the same way
that they were before, because
they find themselves competing
with machines,
and you don't want
to be competing with a $39 piece
of software if you're human.
Not many people want to work
for those kinds of wages.
So in the end, do we come
away with this analysis
as optimists, or
are we pessimists?
Andy and I don't put ourselves
in either the utopian category
or the stagnationist category.
We call ourselves
mindful optimists,
because we believe
that we can address
the challenges and the
opportunities created
by these new technologies,
but that there's
no technological
determinism that's
going to automatically lead
to one future or another.
The book is called "The
Second Machine Age,"
but we learn a lot by looking
at the first machine age, which
was the Industrial Revolution,
and in the Industrial
Revolution, there were
some new technologies,
some wondrous new technologies
that came along that bent
the curve of human history,
that took us from a relatively
stagnant previous
several millennia,
in terms of living
standards, population,
and many other metrics, towards
an explosion of productivity
and increased living standards.
And those technologies primarily
automated physical tasks--
automated our muscles,
like the steam engine,
and later, technologies like
the internal combustion engine.
The second machine
age is much more
about automating cognitive
tasks, mental work,
and we think it's going to have
equally profound implications.
While, when you automate
make muscle tasks,
it actually increases the
demand for control systems,
or cognitive tasks,
and in that sense,
humans tend to be complements
for the automated power
systems.
It's not so clear that
automating cognitive tasks
and augmenting cognitive tasks
is going to be complementary,
versus a substitute,
for human labor.
And as we work through
the implications
of the second
machine age, we need
to think about how we can
make the kinds of adjustments
we made in the
first machine age,
so that we don't just
get the increased
wealth and productivity,
but also the kind of shared
prosperity that we had through
most of the past 200 years.
So with that, let me turn
it over to Andy, who's
going to flesh some of
that out, and then we
want to turn to all of you for
some questions and comments,
and have a robust
discussion about this.
ANDREW MCAFEE: Yeah,
and thank you, Erik.
As Erik says, the main thing
we want to do is talk with you
all, so I don't want to
take up too much time.
I want to do two things.
I want to talk about
where this book came from,
what its origin
was, and then what
its goals became, as
we were writing it,
because if anyone tells
you they know what they're
trying to accomplish
exactly with the book
when they start writing it,
they have just lied to you.
So I want to talk about what our
goals became, as we fleshed out
this book that became
"The Second Machine Age."
I think if honestly
if there were
one day where I had
this eureka moment,
and where I realized that we
needed to go, first of all,
get a lot smarter
ourselves, and then start
writing and publicizing
it to the world,
it would be in the fall of 2010,
when I'm reading the "New York
Times" online, and there
is a story about the fact
that this company developed a
car that was driving itselves
on American roads in traffic,
with no human intervention
whatsoever.
And I spit my coffee at that
point for a very specific
reason-- this was not
supposed to happen.
You all were not
supposed to do this.
Shame on you.
But but more broadly,
the self-driving car
was supposed to remain firmly
in the realm of science fiction,
and not over in the
realm of reality.
We knew this because a
couple of colleagues of ours
had written a fantastic
book six years earlier,
in 2004, explaining, to
our complete satisfaction,
why this driving a car
was going to remain over
on the human side of
the balance sheet,
and not over on
the digital side.
And they made a very
convincing argument
that the pattern-matching
work that
had to go on-- high-stakes
pattern-matching
to drive a car.
If you get it wrong, you're
going to hurt somebody.
The amount of
information you had
to take in, the different
sensory channels you had
to incorporate, the formal
and the informal rules
of the road that you had
to be aware of-- this
was a daunting task.
We humans are kind
of good at it.
Technology was lousy
at it, and that
was the way it was
going to remain,
and Erik and I
both read the book.
We taught it in our
courses, we believed it,
and then you all
screwed up the equation
by basically building a car
that did this kind of stuff.
And then over and over
again, we saw these examples
of science fiction
becoming reality,
and a quote from Hemingway
kept echoing in my head.
He has a wonderful quote
about how a man goes broke.
He says it's gradually
and then suddenly.
And we kept on seeing these
examples of really incremental,
really kind of boring progress,
turning into holy cow,
we're done, eureka, this
mission is accomplished.
How many people have
heard of the problem
in robotics of SLAM?
I just want to see how
geeky this audience is.
Oh, fantastic.
I know something more
than a group at Google.
I'm going to go
home happy today.
SLAM is another thing that
we humans do really easily.
Everyone, point
to the staircase.
Duh.
All of us could locate
where we are in the room
right now, because
we engage in what's
called Simultaneous
Localization and Mapping.
All of us know where the
staircase is in the room.
doors and the hallways are.
We know where we
are in that room.
It turns out it's fiendishly
difficult, astonishingly
difficult, to give a robot that
kind of capability, as well.
There is a review of
the literature on SLAM
that was published, I
believe, in 2008 that said,
we've made essentially
no headway,
and we can't see what's going
to change going forward.
This is one of the holy grails
of the robotics discipline.
A colleague of ours named
John Leonard, back at MIT,
last year, or no more
than a couple years ago,
essentially solved SLAM for
a medium-sized room-- I'm not
making this up-- by
waving a Kinect around.
So he took $150 of
consumer equipment,
and basically solved this
long-standing challenge
in robotics.
So over and over again,
we kept on seeing
these really nasty, thorny
problems just being blown away
by smart geeks working with
incredibly powerful computers
and oceans of data, and that
was really the motivation
to write the book-- for,
first of all, for me and Erik
to understand this world,
and then to communicate it.
And then two other
goals-- the second thing
I want to talk about
is the goals that
appeared as we're writing the
book-- two other goals became
apparent.
The first was that
we felt like we
had to do battle with
two forces out there,
and Erik has talked about them.
One is the force of,
there's nothing new here.
There's nothing to see here.
Move on.
Technology has the same
role in the economy
that it's always
had in the economy.
It's not going to lead to any
bigger or different disruptions
than has gone on before.
I just don't believe
that, and I felt
was important to try
to stake out that turf,
and defend the claim
that honestly, this
is some kind of new regime.
This as a second
machine age here.
The second one is kind of
the opposite of the nothing
to see here.
It's the nothing to worry
about here, because everything
is going to be
hunky-dory because
of technological progress.
We need some utopians out there
who say, oh, you and your silly
worries about jobs and wages
and workers and all that.
We're creating a
world that's going
to be so munificent that
essentially, everything's
going to be free.
No one's going to have a job.
We can all just do Maker
Faire all the time,
and things are going
to be fantastic.
So what are you boring,
Northeast, academic people
worried about?
Just come hang out at
Food Camp for long enough,
and you're going to walk
away just totally optimistic
about the state of the world.
We don't buy that, either.
There are some real
challenges coming up
because of this technological
progress, and to ignore them
is a pretty bad idea.
As Erik said, right
now it's pretty clear
that there's some polarization
and some hollowing out going on
in the middle class of America,
because the stereotypical,
median, American worker does
not have a college education.
Fewer than 40% of us do, and
is not doing manual labor.
They're doing low-level,
fairly routine knowledge work.
As with most of us
know, that is squarely
in the sights of this wave of
progress that we're seeing,
but that wave
doesn't stop there.
Most of us would not call
a doctor a median worker.
Most of us would not
call medical diagnosis
a routine
information-processing task,
but what Watson is doing--
since it's won "Jeopardy,"
it needs a new job-- it
has gone to medical school,
and I'm pretty convinced
that if it is not today
the world's best diagnostician,
it will be fairly quickly.
So these disruptions
in the labor force
are not going to be confined
to that fairly low-wage, fairly
average worker.
They're going to go both
up-- up in the age, the wage,
and the skill, and the
education distribution--
and then downward, as well,
because we're doing things
like learning how to pick fruit
automatically, which is not
a prestigious job, but
certainly a human one now, too.
And then our last
goal was to try
to offer some prescriptions
about what to do,
and I want to be pretty clear.
Our prescriptions
are not out there
in the singularity future
kind of time frame.
Ray Kurzweil has the 2045
turf staked out pretty well.
We don't want to go
encroach on that.
We don't know if
we're going to get
to his version of the future.
One of the funniest things that
ever happened to me, as we were
writing this book-- I
was on stage with a very
prominent roboticist, who
I don't think I'll name,
and he got asked a question
about the singularity.
And he gave a response
that I thought
was incredibly rude,
until I thought
that was incredibly accurate.
He said, look, Ray
Kurzweil is going to die.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So we don't want to be out there
in the 2045 time framework.
What Erik and I are
talking about in the book,
and our recommendations,
focus on time frames a lot,
a lot closer in than that,
and I can bucket them
into two time phases-- things
we could and should do tomorrow,
the immediate stuff, and then
the slightly longer-term stuff.
The immediate stuff
is what you would
learn if you pick any Econ
101 textbook off the shelf.
I don't care if it was
written by Greg Mankiw, who
advises Republican candidates,
or Paul Krugman, who's
a pretty well-known
liberal economist.
Their Econ 101 textbook
would tell a government
to do a small set of
things, and to do them very,
very well-- to do education,
to foster entrepreneurship
in an environment, to
double down and make
sure you've got
world-class infrastructure,
and to have a fairly
welcoming immigration policy,
and to invest in
original research.
This is uncontroversial
among economists.
We think it's exactly the right
the immediate-term playbook
to restart economic growth, and
therefore, restart job and wage
growth, as well.
Looking out slightly
longer term,
the crazy, radical ideas
that we have in the book
are things like-- how many of us
have heard of the Earned Income
Tax Credit?
Good.
This is basically a negative
income tax for people
lower down on the wage
and income distribution.
It rewards a dollar of
work with more than $1
via the income-tax system.
Great idea.
Let's subsidize
labor, especially
at the entry points
of the workforce,
as heavily as we can.
Milton Friedman, that
notorious socialist,
advocated for a negative
income tax a lot.
We think that's
a fantastic idea,
so we believe there are more
than tweaks-- interventions
you can do in things
like the tax code that
will go a long way toward
putting people back to work.
Farther out, again, we
are not singulartarians.
We're not talking about the
economy of 50 years from now.
For what it's worth, I think
it's a science-fiction economy.
I think it's, we're
at the holodeck.
I think we're in
some crazy place,
because you all
are going to keep
doing what you do for
the next 50 years.
It's going to take us into a
world that I can't envision.
What I do know, though,
is it could take us
into a more utopian, kind
of a cool, "Star Trek,"
explore new worlds.
The phrase we use when
we're not talking to geeks
is a digital Athens for that
world, where the citizens have
this enlightened
discourse all the time,
and instead of being
supported by human slaves,
they're supported by
a big army of machines
that do the hard, dirty,
heavy lifting in an economy.
There are dystopian
strains, as well,
and if we continue to
polarize the economy,
if we provide no opportunities,
if mobility continues
to go down-- those are
outcomes that I think push us
in more of a
dystopian direction.
The broadest point I think that
we make when we write the book
is that the choices that
we all make, starting now,
are going to determine
which of those two paths
we create when we head
down, going forward.
I think that's probably
a good place to shut up.
Let's turn this open, and see
what people want to talk about.
You've had your hand
up for a little while.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was just wondering--
you were talking about
negative income taxes,
and one thing that
comes to my mind
is the patent-protection
system, where it essentially
grants government-sanctioned
monopoly to the person doing
the R&D. If technology
improves, would you advocate
some sort of reduction
in the patent window,
because that would increase
competition, and then share?
ANDREW MCAFEE: Yeah, this is
an amazingly controversial area
of work among our colleagues--
IP log and IP regimes,
in general.
The stuff that makes
the most sense to me,
and I want to hear
what Erik says,
are that we've
probably gone too far
with some categories
of IP protection.
It's not clear to me
that software patents
are doing more good than harm.
We might want to revisit that.
Companies like yours buy
these companies mainly
as a war chest for
patents, and then you
go rattle the saber
against some other company,
and then you have some
kind of agreement.
That's not value-added activity.
Amazingly enough,
there's a cartoon
made by Disney called
"Steamboat Willie"
that is still under copyright.
I think it was
made in the 1920s.
It's the precursor to
Mickey Mouse, which
Disney wants to hold
onto tenaciously.
I'm not sure what purpose
is served by that.
So I'm a huge fan of
property, in general,
but I think our property
protections might
have gone a bit too
far in the IP world.
Does that make sense?
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: Yeah, I
think you got it exactly right,
and I would just
elaborate by saying
that the purpose of
intellectual property, according
to the Constitution,
and for that matter,
according to economists, which,
in this case, happen to agree,
is to foster the creative
arts, to foster R&D,
and I think, in
many cases, we've
lost sight of that
with a regime.
It's been taken
over by lobbyists.
The copyright of Mickey
Mouse, and the fact
it's been extended
and re-extended--
there's the Sonny Bono
Copyright Extension Act--
that basically retroactively
extended copyrights.
It's hard to come up
with any rationale
how that would increase the
incentive of people in 1920
to make more inventions
by giving more
wealth to the people who
own those copyrights today.
So that's a perfect--
and then software patents
is another one where, when you
build on previous innovations,
then patents can
discourage innovation,
rather than
providing incentives,
because they basically take away
the returns from the people who
are building the new
stuff, and giving it back
to people who have built
the pre-existing stuff.
So for all those
reasons, there's
some serious re-thinking
that needs to be done,
or actually, returning
to the old thinking that
needs to be done.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
are the greatest risks
to your predictions about
rising unemployment and falling
median income and hollowing
out of the middle class
and so forth?
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
Well, just to be clear,
we're not necessarily
predicting that.
We see that as something that's
happened in the past few years,
and as Andy said
at the end, and I
tried to say at the end, as
well, the outcomes are going
to be very much dependent on
our choices, and when you say,
what are the risks,
do you mean in terms
of risks of us getting it wrong,
or risks that if that happens,
what will be the downside?
There's two interpretations
of the word, risk.
Which one do you
like us to address?
AUDIENCE: What are
the factors most
likely to prevent
those things happening?
ANDREW MCAFEE: What can we do if
we don't like the trajectories?
What can we do?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's partly that
kind of proactive what can we
do, but it might also
be, trends play out
in a way very different--
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
Yeah, yeah, yeah--
AUDIENCE: --than
you would assume.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: --and we
would like to see that happen.
I mean, we can learn a little
bit from the first machine age,
because that was also a
time of great disruption.
It was almost exactly 200
years ago this year-- actually,
it was-- that the
Luddites started
smashing the looms in
the machines in England
because they saw them
as taking away jobs.
And they had a point
that there were
a lot of people-- weavers--
who were losing their jobs,
but at the end, new jobs
were created by the economy,
and you could argue, and it'd
be a fact, that technology
has always been destroying
jobs, and it's always
been creating jobs, and over
time, historically we've
created as many new jobs
as we've eliminated.
Now, those trends have become
decoupled in the past 15 years.
If you look historically,
one of the reasons
that we did create new jobs
was because we, as individuals,
as entrepreneurs, and
as governments, we
made a whole series
of choices, which
helped maintain
shared prosperity.
Just to give you a
couple of examples--
it's been called
America's best idea--
is universal, mandatory
education, and that
helped bring a
bunch of people who
used to be farmers, and give
them a set of skills that made
them suitable for a whole
set of other types of jobs
and occupations, and
America led the world
in pushing that, and
not coincidentally,
led the world in shared
prosperity and living
standards.
But it wasn't just
some government action.
It was also a bunch
of entrepreneurs
that helped invent and
discover the new industries.
90% of Americans used
to work in agriculture.
Now it's less than 2%.
That difference didn't join
the ranks of unemployed,
thankfully.
They were employed in
totally new industries
that people like Henry Ford
and Steve Jobs and Bill Gates
and Larry Page and Sergey
Brin invented that people back
then probably could never
have even conceived of,
so it's very much the
role of entrepreneurs
to help identify what
those new industries are.
The data say that right now,
we aren't doing it as fast
as we used to.
We'd like to see
more entrepreneurship
to help speed up the creative
destruction, especially
the creative side.
Surprisingly, when we
looked at the data,
we found that in
the 2000s, there
were fewer new enterprises
and job creation
than there were in
the '90s or the '80s,
so we think of this as being
a very entrepreneurial era,
but actually, the data suggests
that in some ways, it's not.
If we could speed that up,
if we could, in some sense,
crowdsource this
question of where will
the jobs come from,
which is historically
how we've solved the
problem, we think
we'd be hopeful that we could
improve on that situation.
But we have to say that in
fairness, we are not completely
sure that the future
is going to play out
just the way the past did.
It's been said-- I heard
this from Hal Varian--
that history doesn't
repeat itself,
but sometimes it rhymes.
I'm not sure where you
got that from, but--
ANDREW MCAFEE: Hal Varian looks
a lot like Mark Twain, I think.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: Yeah,
yeah, I think maybe
that's where he got it from.
So maybe we will be
able to replicate
some of the successes,
but I'm sure it's
going to require some
different-- we can't just
double down on doing the exact
same thing we did before.
We're going to have to have some
different kinds of policies,
and that's why we wanted to
start this conversation was
to help identify what
those new changes are
going to need to be.
ANDREW MCAFEE: I like
your question a lot.
I think the main thing that
might make the future play out
differently than I am
envisioning right now
is if Erik and I made the
classic geek mistake, when
we were writing the
book, of becoming too
enamored of the technologies
we were looking at,
and projecting them
too far in the future,
and thinking that their
impact is actually
going to be bigger
than they are.
I don't think we've made
that mistake, but if we have,
then economic growth will
have some really different
consequences, and the
employment impact of technology
will be less than I am
currently thinking it is.
That'd be kind of a
good mistake to make.
AUDIENCE: So a little
more than a year ago,
Paul Krugman wrote
an op-ed in which
he observed that a lot
of the new technologies
are going to start putting more
wealth in the hands of people
that have capital start
with-- people that can afford
the robot army that then
takes away manufacturing jobs.
So I'm wondering what kind
of economic restructuring
do you need to go through
to be able to deal
with that new paradigm?
It almost happened
before, like you've
mentioned, in the
first machine age,
but it seems like it's going
to be on a lot larger scale
this time.
ANDREW MCAFEE: The great
phrase that Krugman used was
"robots and robber
barons," right,
are going to get all the
benefits of the world
that we're creating,
and he thinks
that's a pretty bad outcome.
We do, too.
What can we do to make
sure that doesn't happen?
Again, we're going to sound a
little bit like broken records.
What we don't want to do, what
we're really, really careful--
what we're sure we
don't want to do
is storm the barricades
of capitalism,
and fundamentally rethink the
economic contract right now,
in 2014.
Most of it's
working pretty well.
The biggest problem
that you identify,
and that we spend time on, is
it might get harder and harder
to make a living
from your labor,
as opposed to from your capital.
If that's really what's going
on, let's remove the barriers.
Let's try to upscale our labor.
Let's remove any tax or whatever
distortions to doing that,
and let's see how that goes
before we start thinking
about getting rid of
capitalism or demonizing
capitalists or things like that.
AUDIENCE: So if you
assume that there's
something called structural
unemployment, which,
for my purpose of my
question, means someone whose
potential benefits
of being employed
are less than the costs
of employing them.
I guess my question is,
do you think that exists?
Do you think there's
a population that
fits that category?
How large do you
think it is today,
and what do you think
is going to happen
to that number over the
next coming decades?
ANDREW MCAFEE: Sir?
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: Sure.
There are a number
of ways that you
can get-- the
answer is yes, I can
see there is some
structural unemployment,
and there are a number of
ways you can get to that,
and some of them are
very discouraging.
If you look to-- in the 1930s,
when much of agriculture-- when
tractors were
introduced, mechanizing
a lot of agriculture, Joe
Stiglitz and others have
pointed out that
took tens of millions
of people who used
to work on farms,
and threw them into
the labor force,
and it caused a
macroeconomic, or helped
contribute to a macroeconomic
recession, or the Great
Depression, and it took a
decade or more for many of them
to be reskilled, and
for new industries
to crop up to hire them.
And you can easily see
that that kind of mechanism
could happen today, not with
farmers, because there aren't
any of them left,
hardly-- there's only 2%
of the population
and falling-- but
in, say, routine
information-processing tasks.
And one of the things that
concerns me is that by the time
you find new skills and new
jobs for those people to do,
what if the technology
has changed again?
What if you have
another disruption,
and then you're in this constant
pattern of trying to catch up
with what's going on before?
And if the pace of
technology speeds up,
then you could see
that not only would you
have structural
unemployment, but it
could get more and
more severe over time.
One of the ways this
manifests itself is not
just through unemployment,
but also through inequality.
If you're a true
free-market economist,
you say, well, markets
will always clear.
I mean, you just have let
them clear, and at some level,
that's what the math says.
That's true, but the
wage at which they clear,
the price at which they clear,
could be arbitrarily low.
It could be $5 an hour.
It could be $0.05 an hour.
It could be five-hundreth
of a cent an hour.
And I think most of us would
agree that at least two
of those numbers, and
probably all three of them,
aren't ones we feel very
comfortable as seeing
as the clearing wage for labor.
AUDIENCE: It could be negative.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
Well, if you figure
the cost of hiring somebody--
like right now, if you look
at-- somebody gave me
a horse, and said here,
you can have a horse, and you
can use it to ride to work
and whatever else you
want to do with it,
I'd say, thanks, but no thanks.
I really, even if I got for
free, it wouldn't be worth it.
And so you're certainly right
that an input of production,
once you cover the other
costs associated with it,
even 0 might be
too high a price.
ANDREW MCAFEE: But the question
that Erik and I have wrestled
with the hardest, as we wrote
this book-- we've had not just
bantering, but honest arguments
and disagreements about it--
is, are we heading
into an area where
the average worker is a horse?
In other words, I couldn't walk
up to a factory or a warehouse
or an office park with
a horse and say, hey,
you can have this horse for
a tenth of a penny a day.
Put it to work.
They'd say, get lost.
I have no use for that input
in my system of production
anymore.
We're not headed there
tomorrow or next year
or next five years, even with
this ridiculous technological
progress.
The question I honestly
don't know the answer to
is, are some of us heading into
horse territory in the economy
that we're creating?
Most of the really
smart economists
that we talk to find that a
fairly ridiculous proposition.
I was talking earlier
this week with a guy who's
got a Nobel Prize, and I
said, does your intuition
tell you that if we
play our cards right--
and that's not a
given, obviously,
with the polarization
in Washington
and everything-- if we
play our cards right,
though, that we can be back
to a full-employment economy
after this nasty transition
maybe lasting 20 years?
And he said very confidently,
oh, yeah, absolutely.
We can get back to a
full-employment economy.
I just find myself less
confident than that.
And again, I want to
stress, it's your fault.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: There's no doubt
that technology is contributing
to the hollowing out
of the middle class,
but there's another effect,
which is technologically
related, and I'm
not sure if you're
talking about it
directly or indirectly,
but just the fact that
communication barriers have
come down, and so now a
lot of knowledge work that
used to be done in America
can now be done elsewhere,
which is good for
other countries,
but just not so
great for this one.
So how do those two
variables interact,
and what will the trend be?
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
Well, you're right.
I think that there are
two big trends that
are affecting the
economy today--
globalization and technology.
I mean, there are some
other, smaller trends,
in terms of cultural
changes, unionization,
but just focusing on
those two big ones,
I agree entirely that
globalization is,
in a large part, enabled by
some advances in technology,
especially communications
technologies,
also some transportation
technologies.
But of the two, we think
that the technology one is
the one with more legs, and
the one that's accelerating,
and if you look
at a lot of kinds
of jobs that have been offshored
historically, now many of them
are coming back to
the United States.
Which low-wage
country do you think
Apple, on their
30th anniversary,
is making their
Mac Pro computers?
MALE SPEAKER: USA.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: USA.
They're making them
in Austin, Texas,
not because the wages
are so low in Texas--
maybe we should say,
not just because they're
so low in Texas-- but not
because of the wages there,
but because there's hardly
any labor required anymore.
They're bringing them
back here, and that's
happening for a lot of
knowledge work, as well.
Larry Summers pointed
out to us once
when we were talking
about this that if you
look at manufacturing
employment in China,
how has that changed in
the past 15, 20 years,
as manufacturing
has grown in China?
It's actually fallen.
There are 20
million fewer people
working in manufacturing now
than there were 20 years ago,
so manufacturing employment is
leaving both the United States
and China, not going to
Vietnam, but going to robots.
And so, in many ways, our
view is that if anything,
offshoring is just
a weigh station
on the road to
automation, and some
of these low-wage
countries are even more
in the bulls-eye of automation
in this second machine
age than American or Western
European or Japanese workers,
because the more routine the
tasks are that you're doing,
the easier it is for someone
to write a piece of software,
or a robot or a
program to do that.
And if your competitive
advantage is, hey,
we'll do it for
cheaper, well, I don't
think that's a very
strong barrier to entry,
compared to what's
happening with the pace
of technological change.
ANDREW MCAFEE: And
you asked specifically
about knowledge work.
I came across this really
interesting series of stories
in the press awhile
back, because
some different
reporters noticed it,
and then they were calling
up their insurance company
or their credit card
company or their bank.
They seem to be interacting
with this perfectly accented
American voice that was
giving them somewhat canned
responses, with the same
sentences or sentence fragments
over and over again.
And so they pushed
on that, and they
noticed that they think there
are two different strains going
on right now.
One is where there's a Filipino
listening to what they're
saying, because English
skills are pretty good there,
and then pressing
a button for which
American-accented
response they're
supposed to spit
back on the fly.
The slightly more
advanced version of that
is there's an algorithm
listening to what the person is
saying, and the
algorithm hits the button
for which pre-recorded human
voice should be given back
to the person.
Step three of that
progression, I believe, is--
we have all seen
the movie "Her"--
is Scarlett Johansson's
synthetic voice is just going
to give us a response back.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: That's the
future we're all hoping for.
ANDREW MCAFEE: Yeah, exactly,
can't get here soon enough.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW MCAFEE: But it's not
science fiction stretched
anymore to imagine a completely
synthetic interaction
like that.
Again, for knowledge
work, we think
that offshoring
is a weigh station
on the way to automation.
AUDIENCE: How much
do you think this
is a US issue, versus
a global issue?
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: Well, it's
certainly a global issue.
I mean, if you look
at the-- I mean,
a lot of the trends we gave
were using US numbers, frankly,
because we are the most
familiar with them,
and some of the best
data is available here,
but if you look at the OECD,
the Organization of Economic
Cooperation and Development,
the most developed countries,
you see a very similar pattern.
For instance, the hollowing
out of routine jobs
has happened in virtually
every one of those industries,
according to research by
my colleague, David Autor,
and others.
The inequality has grown
in all those countries.
It has grown in Sweden,
Germany, France, Japan.
There's only two
or three countries
where it hasn't grown-- Greece
and, I think, one other one,
and there's just
some weird things
going on in those countries
that probably aren't typical.
And as we just said, when you
look at the developing nations,
you see, I think
arguably, that they
may be even more
in the bulls-eye,
and I think this could be a real
concern, because historically,
having low wages and taking
some of those kinds of jobs
in textiles and other areas
has been a path to development
to get out of that
underdeveloped state.
You for awhile do those
really low-wage jobs,
and then, as you work
your way up the ladder,
you start joining
the broader economy.
If that path is cut off,
it could be very troubling.
Those countries that
haven't made the transition
may be stuck for a long time on
the other side of the ledger.
ANDREW MCAFEE: There
was a nice piece
of work done by a couple
of University of Chicago
economists just recently
that looked at the returns
to capital versus labor in many
countries around the world,
and they found the pattern
was really similar, almost
without exception.
The share of total GDP that
was getting paid out in labor
was heading south country
after country after country
around the world.
We can think of an
explanation for that
doesn't involve technology.
And in fact, they said the
explanation is explicitly
information technology.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
Right, and I think
that that's a very important
point to emphasize,
is because there are
people who say well, it's
because of what
their Congress did,
or what the guys in Wall
Street did, or whatever,
and I'm sure there have been
a lot of bad things done
in Washington and Wall
Street and elsewhere,
but the fact that this pattern
is so pervasive and so global
suggests to us, or is
additional evidence to us,
that there are some more
fundamental economic forces
and technological
forces at work.
AUDIENCE: I think once you
have big problems like health,
and legal system politics
become automated,
like having a differential
diagnosis done
by a machine or a
phone app, and it
tells you exactly
what's happening,
you probably have
more trust of a better
diagnosis than the
best doctor out there,
and for this layer of very
high-paid cognitive type
of skills, there is a lot
of infrastructure built
to protect this system, and a
lot of politics and lobbyists
that want to make
sure that it stays.
And can we create
a baseline for,
let's say, before we
go that route, there
needs to be a unanimous approval
on what can go-- not to serve
a particular interest of a
certain group, but rather,
humanity at large?
ANDREW MCAFEE: So no is
the short answer to that.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: After that
polite way of [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDREW MCAFEE: Yeah, it
was a lovely question.
I'm going to dismissive answer.
No, we certainly can't change
our political structure
that deeply, so we have
to have a plebiscite
before every instance
of technological change
and lobbying protect-- we're
not going to get there.
But you bring up a
really important point,
which is that-- I
won't speak for Erik--
I think that the main impediment
to a lot of the stuff,
the great stuff, that
we're going to see
is exactly the barriers
that you identify--
our regulatory barriers that
are there to protect incumbents,
as opposed to protecting
consumers-- they primarily
have that effect-- are
lobbying groups or all
the forces of inertia
that are trying
to keep stuff from happening.
When you look at the-- some
of Uber's recent troubles
are self-inflicted.
Let's be really
clear about that.
Some of the other
ones have been brought
on by exactly the
forces you identify.
Did you all hear
that France is making
Uber wait a minimum
of 15 minutes
before the car can show up
purely to protect their taxis.
This is insane, but we're
going to see all kinds of stuff
like that go on.
Stupid question
time-- how many of
us have heard of Tim O'Reilly?
Heh heh.
Dumb, right?
Tim has a beautiful
way to phrase it,
and it's something
that I carry around.
He says, look, with our policy
and our regulatory decisions,
we have two choices.
We can protect the
past from the future,
or we can protect the
future from the past.
For heaven's sake, let's protect
the future from the past.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
Right, and that's
not to say that there aren't
policies that we should adopt,
but I 100% agree with Andy
that there's a natural reaction
to either smash the machines,
the Luddite approach,
or to freeze the existing
occupations and jobs the way
they are through a whole set
of occupational licensing
and another incumbent
protection acts.
And while those seem
like natural ways
to prevent some of
the bad outcomes,
ultimately we
think they're going
to be more destructive
than beneficial.
The way that the economy
has thrived in the past
has been what does
Joseph Schumpeter called
creative destruction,
and the answer
is not to try to slow
down the new ideas
and the new technologies.
It's to speed up our
adaptation, and the government
can help in many ways by, for
instance, I mentioned earlier,
universal public education was
one idea, and raising the skill
levels.
Encouraging, boosting, and
speeding entrepreneurship--
not slowing it down.
Doing things with tax
policy, doing things
with R&D. So there
are lots of things
you can do to help
with the preconditions
to smooth and speed
the transition,
but freezing in the
historical structure
is certainly going to
do more harm than good.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so
companies like Apple
make money by building fancy
gadgets to sell to consumers,
and companies like Google make
money by allowing advertisers
to advertise their fancy gadgets
to consumers, and all of this
requires that the consumers
are there, and they have jobs,
and they have--
MALE SPEAKER 2: Money.
AUDIENCE: --money.
So in a sense, we
have an interest
in making sure that this
situation you talked
about where workers turn into
horses doesn't actually happen.
Are there any economic
models which talk about this,
and say that there might
be some kind of tipping
point where it all gets into
a horrible, negative feedback
loop, and?
ANDREW MCAFEE: We can we
can summarize the situation
you're describing, in
an apocryphal story
about Henry Ford II
and Walter Reuther, who
was the head of the
auto workers' union.
There's a story
about the two of them
going through a very highly
automated, brand new plant
that Ford had
built, and they were
kind of joshing with each other.
I'm sure they hated
each other deeply,
but they were kind of
joshing with each other,
and Henry Ford points to one
of his new pieces of equipment,
and he says, hey,
Walter, how are you
going to get those
robots to pay union dues?
And Reuther says, hey,
Henry, how are you
going to get them to buy cars?
So this is exactly the problem
but that you're identifying.
If people are out of work, if
their wages are going down,
aggregate demand in
the economy goes down,
we know that's a really
bad thing to have happen,
and what I don't know is
how soon is this coming?
How bad will it be?
But any reluctance
to spend is going
to cause the economy
and overall demand
to head in the wrong direction,
and that reluctance to spend
can be based in
reality, or it can
be based on Keynes'
famous animal spirits.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
Right, and the example
I gave earlier about what
happened in the Great
Depression-- Joe
Stiglitz described that
as being one of the contributing
factors to that fall in demand,
and so it's going to potentially
have macroeconomic effects, as
well as these
distributional effects.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to ask you something
personal and specific.
ANDREW MCAFEE: And I see
we're just about out of time.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Last week there
was a lengthy article
in the "Economist" about
the future of jobs,
and it liberally
quoted from you--
ANDREW MCAFEE: Not liberally
enough, I'll tell you that.
AUDIENCE: --in your
upcoming book, and so
I wanted to ask you if you are a
parent, or want to be a parent,
what would you
advise your children
to do who are going to enter
the workforce in the next two
decades?
What careers and what kind
of education opportunities
should they pursue, because
the classic types of things
that maybe we have told them in
the past-- go become a lawyer,
go become an accountant,
go become a doctor.
This is a ticket to
professionalism, upper middle
class lifestyle, and the odds
of you becoming unemployed
are very low, and I
don't feel that that
is going to be the case
going forward anymore,
and so I want to
put that on you,
and if you had to
advise your own son
or daughter, what would you say?
ANDREW MCAFEE: Let's have
the parent answer first.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: It's a good
question, and it's a tough one,
but there are still
some categories
that machines are
not very good at,
and we are hesitate to--
we almost never say never
because of what we've seen
in terms of advances--
but things that involve
significant amounts
of creativity, invention,
entrepreneurship.
Those have not been
affected at all.
In fact, they've been augmented.
They've become more valuable.
Interpersonal interactions
and skills-- machines so far
are still not very
good, although we've
got friends in the Media Lab
and elsewhere that are there
pushing the frontiers on that,
but whether that's motivating
people, or even just
caring for a sick child,
comforting somebody--
that's something
that machines don't
seem to be very good at.
I would encourage my
kids to be flexible,
because whatever types of tasks
that are or aren't automated
now-- it's likely to
change, and people
are going to have
to change and adapt
much more quickly
than in the past.
So we don't know for
sure exactly which
categories are going
to be affected.
Those are some of them, but
maintaining that flexibility
is probably going to be one of
the key things you can do you.
ANDREW MCAFEE: You asked
a personal question.
I'll give a little bit
of a personal answer.
I'm not a parent, but
the most common question
that we get asked
about this stuff
comes from parents
of kids of all ages
saying, what advice do I give?
What do I do?
So my advice for
parents of young kids
is actually a lot easier for me.
I say, just send
them to Montessori.
And not that that's a panacea.
Are there Montessori
kids in the room?
Really?
That's amazing.
If one or both your
founders were in the room,
hands would be going up.
There's a Montessori mafia
among the technology elite,
and I was a Montessori kid, too.
And what it taught
me is that the world
is a really interesting
place, and your job
is to go poke at it.
I think that's great.
My school only went up
through the third grade,
so in the fourth grade, I went
into the public school system
in the Indiana town
where I'm from,
and I felt like I had
been sent to the Gulag.
I'm like, you want me
to sit here all day,
and a series of things
is going to be inflicted
on me at 45-minute intervals?
What are you people, sadists?
It just made no sense
to me, whatsoever.
So early on, go teach
your kids that the world
is an interesting place.
At the college level, my
silly bumper sticker advice
is put down the
beer pong paddle,
and just go do a double major.
Go hang out with the theater
geeks at one side of campus,
and the math geeks at
the other side of campus.
Fill up your toolkit
as much as you can.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: And the only
other thing I would add to that
is that if we do tend to more
of a winner take all market,
there's even more of a premium
than there was in the past
on being the very
best in something,
so it becomes important
to pursue things
that you're really
passionate about,
that you're interested
in, because we all
know that you're not likely
to be the best at anything
that you're just doing
because you have to
or because you're supposed to.
But there are going to
be niches-- large niches
and small niches and tiny
ones-- where somebody
has the potential to be
among the best in the world,
and those are the
ones that are still
going to be in demand, whereas
if you just another person
doing a job because
you have to, it's
going to be increasingly
hard for people
to find a way to make
a living doing that.
AUDIENCE: We seem to
take it for granted
that investing education
is a wise thing
to do, at least on a
macroeconomic scale,
but on a personal
scale, given the rising
popularity and prosperity,
if I'm not rich,
and my prospect of becoming
well-off are very, very slim,
why should I be motivated to
invest in educating myself
if the chances of that having
me better off are so low?
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
Well, the data
suggests that even today,
the difference in earnings
between people with more
education and less education
is enormous, and
it's been growing,
so from a purely selfish,
personal point of view,
it does pay to get
more education.
But it's important
to understand,
when we talk about
education, first off,
we don't just mean college
or post-graduate education.
We mean all levels, whether
it's K through 12, vocational,
lifelong learning-- all of them
building more human capital
in any of those dimensions
is likely to add value.
But we also think that education
has to be reinvented exactly
along the lines that Andy
was describing earlier.
The traditional pattern of
having people sit in rows,
and learn to follow
instructions carefully
from the person at the
front of the room-- well,
following instructions is
something that machines
are really pretty good at doing,
so education of that model,
and imparting facts
and numbers, isn't
likely to be the
kind of thing that we
need more of the future.
Education that
sparks creativity,
that allows you to think about
new ways of putting things
together, and create
things-- that's much more
likely to be something
that adds value.
ANDREW MCAFEE: Here, here.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
a wonderful talk.
So coming back to
this policy question,
how aware would you
say the average policy
maker or politician in
US is about these trends,
and how could we actually
get more of our politicians
to understand the nuance of
what you're talking about?
ANDREW MCAFEE: Someone needs
to write a book about it.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW MCAFEE: You can either be
really pessimistic or somewhat
optimistic about it.
I'd say the awareness is early,
early days, but growing kind
of quickly, and everyone
that we talk to,
these really well-informed
people, bemoan
the polarization in Washington,
and this environment we have
where, if you say
black, by definition,
I'm going to say white.
But the green shoots
that we see are
around some pretty important
areas, like immigration policy.
There is a pretty broad
bipartisan agreement
that we need to
change some things.
There's a lot of talk about how
we need to reinvent education.
No one's exactly sure
how we need to do that.
So I would say the awareness
is, especially about this tech
stuff, because Washington's
not a technophilic place,
the awareness is low.
It's getting better
kind of quickly,
and maybe it'll get
OK at some point.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
Yeah, I mean, that's
certainly one of the
more depressing parts
of our analysis is
just the way things are
so stagnant in Washington and
in public policy, in general.
There is a growing
amount of anger,
whether it's the Tea Party
or Occupy Wall Street,
or other groups, but our sense
is that, by and large, they
mostly have misdiagnosed
the nature of the problem,
and if you don't have
the right diagnosis,
you're probably not going to
have the right prescriptions.
And so a big part of the reason
we wrote this book was to help
change the conversation.
Ultimately we've
been told by people
who know better-- Washington
doesn't lead the country.
It's people who
lead it, and they
will respond to what
people are demanding.
So phase one is
spreading the awareness,
as I think you just
brought up, getting people
to understand some of the
issues that are important,
and once that conversation
has been changed,
we're going to have much
better hope of changing
the kinds of policies.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked quite a bit
about what regulators
can do to counteract
some of these effects.
Is anything we can do,
given that at Google we
are pushing technology forward
and are often techno-optimists?
ANDREW MCAFEE: Yes, stop, OK?
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: No, no, no.
ANDREW MCAFEE: No, don't.
That's the first thing.
This is actually
really important.
We come across a lot of
really well-meaning people
who kind of want you guys
to stop what you're doing,
and want the tech sector
to slow down and stop
putting people out of work.
We think that's the single-worst
idea that we come across,
so by all means, carry on
taking us into the future.
It's incredibly important work.
As individuals, advocate,
support enlightened policies,
vote for and support people
who are taking our policies
in the right direction, and just
participate in the democracy.
Our friend Larry Lessig
talks about how we just
feel so disengaged
from the process,
and we've become increasingly
cynical about it.
Just don't do that, please.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: You
know, technology-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I think I
meant in between, so--
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: Yeah, yeah.
Let me try and go
to that, because I
think that the technologists
and engineers have been
great at solving
problems, and we talked
to some of the folks that
responded to the first DARPA
Grand Challenge, which
was, as you know probably,
to build a driverless car,
which many people thought
was impossible,
and they responded.
The new DARPA Urban Challenge
is a robot-- six-foot,
Atlas robot-- that weighs about
300 pounds that actually will
be able to walk up to a
vehicle, open the door,
get inside, drive it, get
out, walk across rubble, up
some stairs, attach a hose,
a whole set of other tasks.
And again, at first it
seemed like science-fiction
impossibility, but our friends
at the MIT Computer Science
and AI Lab and elsewhere seem
to be making headway on that.
It may be that we need
to think about a new kind
of grand challenge that isn't to
make an amazing new technology,
but is just to think
about how we can reinvent
an economic, social,
organizational system--
one that creates as many
jobs as it's automating.
Many of the previous
engineering tasks have either
implicitly or quite
explicitly been designed
to answer the
question, how can we
take labor out of this process?
How can we make this
more labor-saving,
and have a machine do what a
person used to be able to do?
But technology
doesn't have to just
be a substitute for humans.
Many technologies can be
complements for humans,
and can enhance the
value of humans,
and maybe if we put
more focused effort
into a grand challenge for
creating technologies that
boost the amounts of labor,
that are complements to labor,
and allow people to do things
they couldn't have done before,
then we are likely to get that
kind of shared-prosperity world
that we were hoping for.
And so that would be the
kind of grand challenge.
We haven't quite figured out
how to formulate that right,
but maybe if we
could do that, it
would inspire many
of you and people
elsewhere in the
country and the world
to try to solve that
problem, as opposed
to waiting for, say,
Washington to take action.
ANDREW MCAFEE: I think we have
time for one more question,
but it has to be a really
bang-up final question.
Are you ready?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Maybe.
So actually, that was a
really interesting answer,
if under-specified so far,
that you started to give,
because before you
started to give that,
I would've started to
wonder if you had had
the reaction-- other people
had the reaction to the book
that your proposed
prescriptions don't seem
of the same magnitude as the
problem that you're describing.
For the most part, you seem
to just be describing tweaks,
or maybe if you
have one big idea,
it's education, which everybody
has talked about for years,
and nobody knows how to fix,
and if you could fix it,
it wouldn't pay off for
decades down the line anyway,
and you have new
problems by that point.
So what do you think is the
biggest policy prescription
or advice for the
future that you
have that is proportionate to
the magnitude of the problem?
ANDREW MCAFEE: And the nastiest
and maybe most accurate
comment we've gotten
about our work
is, you guys are
proposing linear solutions
to an exponential situation.
Ow, right?
So we're mindful of it.
What we don't want
to do is say that we
know what the trajectory of
technology is going to be,
and therefore what kind
of moonshotty intervention
is appropriate to get there.
What we're saying instead is
essentially, let's iterate.
Let's tinker.
Let's mess with the
things that we know
will move the dial in
the right direction,
and let's make sure that we're
tracking the problem correctly,
as opposed to trying to
anticipate where this thing is
going to be in some crazy
time frame down the road.
I take a lot of insight from
your chairman's repeated
assertion that the crazy,
long-frame planning
horizon for Google
is five years.
Overshooting that by a lot
with our policy recommendations
seems like a recipe for
failure or disaster.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
I mean, you've
raised a very
important point, which
is that we don't have a
silver-bullet solution to this.
I wish we did,
but we can't point
to one silver-bullet
solution, and that partly
reflects how we went
about writing this book.
Many people who write this kind
of book start with a policy,
and then they go
and write a bunch
of reasons why this policy
needs to be put in place.
ANDREW MCAFEE: Because
they're policy guys.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON: Right.
We are not policy
guys, and we focused
on diagnosing what's going on.
We want to lay those issues out.
We have three chapters' worth
of potential solutions that we
think will help
with the problem,
but ultimately we think that
by start this conversation,
maybe you and others in this
room and elsewhere will help
develop the solutions.
We lay out some of
the problems there,
and this is the kind of thing
that, just as in the past,
we hope to crowdsource
it, in essence.
And we have tried to walk
the walk a little bit,
in terms of starting
a new initiative
on the digital economy at MIT,
where we were bringing together
people to grapple
with these questions,
and we're hoping we
can make some progress.
But I have to confess,
I can't say here,
if you just implemented
the Earned Income Tax
Credit, the problem
will be solved,
because it's not
going to be that easy.
AUDIENCE: A very
brief follow-up--
when you're in a
ditch, stop digging.
What's the single-most
thing that we shouldn't
do to make the problem worse
than maybe we are already
doing?
ANDREW MCAFEE:
Turning out people
who do not have the skills to be
valuable workers in the economy
of today, let alone tomorrow.
The business leaders that we
talk to are so frustrated.
Up and down the
skill ladder, they
can't find the people
that they need, even
for the positions they have
open, even here in America.
That just doesn't
make any sense.
ERIK BRYNJOLFSSON:
I would second that.
I would also say
that there's been
a problem of siloing
technical people,
from the economists
and the policy makers.
We find that these groups that
we've tried to bridge just
don't speak the same language.
They don't even recognize
the same problems,
and if we could get people
coordinating on those,
I think that would
be half the battle.
ANDREW MCAFEE: Thank
you all for coming.
This is fantastic.
[APPLAUSE]